how's it going everyone this is Daniel
from the chess website and Welcome to
our video on the top seven chess
openings for beginners so this video is
obviously geared towards players who are
just starting out chess you might have a
basic sense of strategy and tactics and
even opening principles and things like
that we're going to be providing you
with seven reliable openings that you
can use with your own games there'll be
four openings with white three open
openings with black and what I want to
keep in mind is these openings will be
geared towards following the opening
principles the opening principles being
controlling the center you want to
develop your pieces efficiently and
obviously King safety is very important
but also the criteria that we will be
that we will be meeting for these
openings will be just sort of
playability
we don't want you to be bogged down with
a bunch of theory and very complicated
positions we want to be relatively
simple and an opening that you can enjoy
playing and learning from so with that
said let's get to it so we will start
with the white openings and the first
two openings actually deriv from the
moves E4 E5 so we put our E Pawn out
we're controlling the center we're
letting our Bishop and potentially Our
Queen out black does the same we play
Knight to F3 and one of our other
suggestions we're going to look at a
different knight move on the second move
but after Knight F3 Knight C6 the first
suggestion is called the Italian the
Italian is probably the most popular
opening suggestion for beginners it's
this move Bishop C4 and the Italian that
is what defines the Italian when you put
the bishop on C4 if you put on B5 it's
called the Spanish if you play D4 which
we'll look at here in a second second
it's called the scotch if you play
Knight C3 it's three Knights which could
transpose to Four Knights there are many
different ways to take this so Bishop C4
is the Italian why is the Italian so
principled well you're developing your
Bishop closest to the center possible as
you can see you're controlling the D5
Square which is one of the four Center
squares you also have the bishop nicely
placed to potentially attack things or
Target things on F7 there's already a
weakness that you can sort of exploit
and also you're preparing to potentially
Castle next move so after Bishop to C4
there are a few options that black can
play and this isn't really a big opening
Theory video this is just to get some
ideas but black plays Knight F6 you can
play a move like D3 and then sort of
slow play it or you can go for f fried
liver with night G5 which there's
definitely content about so feel free to
check that out if black plays the move
Bishop C5 then there are many options
you could Castle you could play D3 you
could play C3 ultimately what you'll be
doing is you'll want to castle at some
point and then develop your pawns as
well as your pieces you might be putting
your Bishop on E3 or G5 depending on
what the position calls for maybe
putting the Knight on D2 and then
preparing some queenside Advance there
are a lot of potential plans that you
can go about and again there are a bunch
of resources as far as the opening
Theory goes to these opening
so feel free to check those out the
other e45 opening that I would suggest
with white is to play this move Pawn to
D4 this is called the scotch now the
reason why I like the scotch is because
from the get-go you open both of your
Bishops as well as controlling the
center which is already something you
should be doing anyway so after Pawn to
D4 black will normally take if black
doesn't take then they invite you to
either take the pawn on E5 or push with
D5 so black takes then we take then the
game can go several directions black
could play Bishop C5 black play Knight
F6 a position like this is very common
maybe something like Bishop B4 and then
Knight takes takes Bishop D3 and you
just have a very pleasant position where
you have the two Bishops you're going to
Castle very soon you have a nice Pawn in
the center and you are good to go the
next opening that we will be suggesting
you look into to from the white side is
actually not developing your knight to
F3 it's developing your knight to C3 now
Knight to C3 is called the Vienna game
and the reason you develop your knight
to C3 rather than playing Knight F3 is
you keep the F Pawn on F2 with the
possibility that you might play a move
like F4 later in the game now there are
a couple of ways to approach this black
will normally play a move like Knight F6
and there are a couple of ways you can
approach it you can play Bishop C4 D3
and then F4 this is more of a Vienna
game or you could play an immediate
Vienna Gambit which is when you play F4
and if the pawn is taken then you play
E5 and now the Knight is sad so black
will normally play something like D5 and
then there will be takes takes and then
move like Queen F3 is pretty common so
on and so forth so you could play Vienna
Gambit if you want a very sharp game and
good opportunities for your opponents to
mess up or if you want to be more
positional more quiet you could play
Move Like Bishop C4 and play D3 F4
Knight G to E2 and then just slow play
it from there the next wide opening we
will be looking at and the last wide
opening is the very controversial London
system now is the London is the London
system objectively that good I mean it's
all right the thing about the London
system it's it's very easy to remember
you put your Pawn out then you play
Knight F3 you play Bishop F4 and then
you sort of make a pawn triangle with E3
and C3 you'll put your Bishop on D3
Knight on D2 you castle and it's very
solid as you can see black tries to
maybe instigate some Pawn tension with
C5 but we don't even budge cuz if they
take we can just take back with either
or C Pawn so we are good to go there and
again as I as I'd say with all these
openings there are a lot of resources
out there to check to check out as far
as Theory and specific plans go this
hope this video is just sort of a
guideline to these openings that we'd
recommend you pursue if you're a
beginner and what I would say with black
is we looked at two openings in response
to E4 and one in response to D4 there's
so many openings that we could have
looked at so if you have any suggestions
that we might have missed feel free to
link them in the comments or write them
in the comments so against
E4 I would say one opening we would
suggest is to play this move E5 the
upside is that just like white you are
controlling the center you're developing
your pieces or preparing to do so and
you know just after play like Knight F3
Knight C6 it can be very just sort of
you know streamline line very you know
symmetrical you're following the
principles you're controlling the center
you're preparing to Castle the downside
is that there could be some crazy
gambits and things like that that you
have to be prepared for like already on
move two you have to be prepared for
like the king's Gambit there might even
be like some Scotch gambits you have to
be prepared for so there are some
downsides to that however I probably
would also say that if you're a beginner
you shouldn't be worried too much about
opening Theory just learn the ideas you
know learn from your mistakes and follow
the opening principles and so maybe a
safer option is the very popular KOC con
defense which is this move C6 now at
First Sight when you're thinking control
the center develop your pieces Castle
you might be thinking well what does C6
do it doesn't really seem to do much
sure maybe we're getting our Queen out
but what good does that do the idea
behind scen D6 is next move to
springboard your Pawn to D5 so you play
Pawn to D5 you're attacking the E Pawn
and controlling the center and now white
has to make a decision they could
protect they could advance or they could
take and there are obviously more moves
than just those those three moves but
those are the main moves and so if white
protects you can play Move Like Bishop
F5 then start activating your pieces if
white takes you just take back
and then you play chess if white
protects then you can play takes and
then you could go Bishop F5 or a knight
F6 is also a move and then again you
just develop from there so that is
called the kocon the last opening that
we will be suggesting is an opening
against D4 is sort of a semis slav so
after D4
D5 if white just plays like a London or
something Norm normal you'll just be
able to develop your pieces normally
without much issue but if white plays
this very popular opening called the
Queen's Gambit then you can play sort of
a semis slav it doesn't really matter
which Pawn you start with E6 or C6 you
could go either way the point is sort of
like the London system you're getting
this Pawn triangle to work with and so
play might develop something like Knight
F3 Knight F6 develop your big Bishop
castle and in some variations you might
be able to take and play B5 although
that could get pretty complicated cuz it
would it would potentially surrender the
center but anyway I think this is a very
reliable way to play what I will note is
that when you do play the semi slav you
are locking in your bishop and it's not
very opportune let's say you go C6 first
it's not a very good idea to get your
Bishop out early in the slav because
this B7 Pawn is weak as is the sord of
D5 Square so white has some very
concrete variations with taking and then
going Queen B3 and the B7 pawns attacked
the D5 pawns attacked it's suddenly sort
of feeling the absence of the bishop so
yeah those are the seven openings that
we would suggest you look at the Italian
the scotch the Vienna the London the
kocan E5 and the semis slav all right I
hope you have a great rest of your day
feel free to let us know know what you
think in the comments and I will see you
for the next video take care